Good morning Hank, it's Friday.
It's Question Friday,
the day that I answer real questions from
real Nerdfighters.
[Intro music]
"Are you going to live in Indianapolis forever?"
Well, no,
I'm going to spend
the vast majority of forever deceased.
"Are you a rebel?"
No; I've always been for the Empire,
that's no secret.
The world needs order.
And death stars.
"Are you aware that, on average,
your videos that do discuss giraffe mating
get ten times more views
than your videos that don't
discuss giraffe mating?"
Yeah, I don't know what it is exactly,
but for some reason, as previously noted,
people love giraffes who love giraffes.
Maybe it's because the mating habits of the
giraffe are profoundly fascinating.
For instance, did you know
(and by the way this is all going to be disturbing)
when boy giraffes wanna have babies
with girl giraffes,
the first thing that they do
is use their heads
to nudge the girl giraffes in their lady parts.
They do this
(and by the way, Hank,
you may want to put a bucket nearby)
because it causes the girl giraffes to pee,
and then the boy giraffes drink the pee
because they can taste whether or not the
girl giraffes are ovulating.
[Gags, coughs]
Sorry...
I pictured it, I pictured it.
"Are you thinking what I'm thinking?"
Ummm...
if you're thinking that urine-swilling giraffe sex
is the most profoundly unerotic
thing you've ever heard of,
then yes. Otherwise,
you disgust me.
"Are you trying to take over the world using
muffins and silly string?"
Hank, we've been found out.
"Are you gonna come to my graduation party?"
No, but where is it? I'll send an emissary.
"Are you my father?"
Let me answer your question with a question:
Are you a nine-month-old West Highland Terrier
with an indomitable desire to eat shoes?
If not: no.
"Are you stuck in the labyrinth?"
In the labyrinth, but not stuck.
"Are you thinking about writing more books?"
Yes. I am contracted to write at least three
more books, so don't worry.
"Are you even reading this?"
Well, I was, but now I'm doing something else.
"Are you an optimist with regard to
the future of humanity?"
Well, I'm an optimist in the sense that I think
our relentless attempt to extinguish the species
will fail for the forseeable future.
...Yay!
"Are you Kurt Vonnegut?"
Dude, I wish!
"Are you Santa?"
No! Santa's black.
"Are you Gandalf?"
You shall not...
I mean ,who am I kidding?
My wizard stick is an umbrella. Also,
[Laughing] I don't think Gandalf
calls it a wizard stick.
"Are you King James II of England?"
Well, I'm not Catholic,
I'm not British,
and I don't have shoulder-length curly hair-
and, if I did, I wouldn't part it in the middle.
"Are you a banana?"
Oh, come on, these questions
are just getting stupid,
like, do I have some kind of
pale exterior that you can peel away
and then find edible meat inside?
Oh... yes.
But, do I thrive in tropical climates?
Oh my God,  I am a banana.
"Are you gonna put Bubbles the Nerdfighting
Puppy in a video soon?"
"Are you Jacques Derrida?"
Je vais à la bibliothèque
...is the only sentence I know in French.
Therefore, I'm probably not Jacques Derrida.
"Are you a 40-year old virgin ROFL?"
...Is a question that was asked
by someone who doesn't know
the proper placement of question marks.
"Are you gonna do your happy dance
immediately after reading my question?"
Yes! [Stomping] Yes!
Hank, happy 2009!